[Music]
was it the holidays it wasn't that well
then why you decide to come in tonight
trying to fix my mind Howard is a
brilliant man and he's not just the boss
he's a friend
he lost his child and now he doesn't
care if he loses everything else this
might be the strangest thing I have ever
come across he writes letters who are
they - Howard doesn't write letters to
people he writes to things time love
death kids write letters a Santa Claus
it doesn't mean the crazy no this is
therapeutic you don't think I'm crazy
but having conversations death came
first she met me in the dog park charmed
I'm sure
so death is or her turns out death is an
elderly white woman come into me I'm
time you wrote me because you need
Howard ask him what ask her if she can
see me he was sitting right here and he
just appeared right
I'm love a minor fabric of life
something's trying to happen to you
Howard
I don't know what to do to bring you
back
what if love death and time for trying
to help you you need to talk to them
Howard challenged them just in game
the reason for everything about you
every day
when she laughs and you broke my heart I
was back in her love but I'm also here
now in your pain
he's reaching out to the cosmos advances
just be sure to notice the collateral
beauty it's the profound connection to
everything except that maybe he gets to
find his life again
not here to take me are you know Howard
I'm here to write the F train with you
let's love tonight every single human
being on earth we long for love we wish
we had more time and we fear death